fun france par sa peu un rêve parce que
dans les réalisateurs quand j'ai vu my
beautiful laundrette pour moi cela me
rappelait un peu curieusement le jeu
plus fine des clash mais avec scénario
sert typiquement anglais est une manière
d'approcher les la jeunesse et ce qui se
passe en angleterre avec des images
crues et en même temps ça tienne la
route s'est pas retrouvée qui je pensais
qu'il était vachement jeunes tous primés
comme ça en fait je me suis trouvée
c'est pas un ppv où il a bien la
cinquantaine
espèce de bonhomie comme ça voire j'ai
bien j'aime bien le tournage que j'avais
envie en plus pour l'histoire et à celle
bien de parler se manipule écrit jamais
d'histoire bîmes a mis pas mal en fait
le pied à l'étrier sûr essayer faire la
mise en scène c'est humain qui décide
est un peu de la manière dont on allait
faire les plans
mais quand je regarde le résultat je
m'aperçois qu'il a mis beaucoup de sa
manière de voir les planches choyer les
filets du combien de temps met pas
longtemps la fois il ya dix jours passés
bien tout récent